gérald ollivier journaliste chercheur à
l'ipp ce l'institut prospective et
sécurité de l'europe
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors dans quelle
mesure les tensions raciales la gestion
de la crise sanitaire également change
la face de la campagne présidentielle
bonjour bien sûr je ferai une
distinction entre tensions raciales
écrits du port un virus et je vous
trouve très gentil de qualifier ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui de tensions
raciales parce que ça n'a absolument
plus d'un notamment à seattle ou à
portland
donc vous parler un petit peu plus tôt
cela n'a absolument plus rien à voir
avec l'incident de gens je flotte
c'est à dire qu'on est dans certaines
villes aujourd'hui qui se trouvent être
des villes gérées depuis des décennies
par des démocrates
on est dans une situation semi
insurrectionnel avec la volonté de la
part des gestionnaires de ces villes de
laisser le chaos s'installer pour créer
une idée que quand trump est au pouvoir
eh bien il évita blement cela génère le
chaos dans la rue c'est une des
tactiques des démocrates pour essayer de
faire que 30 soit battu en novembre lors
de l'élection présidentielle donc cette
crise là c'est une crise qui n'a rien à
voir avec le racisme qui a tout à voir
avec l'élection présidentielle et qui
est simplement le ressort de la façon
dont les démocrates entendent gérer les
choses d'ici à l'élection
c'est une chose maintenant le virus lui
même c'est vrai que c'est une crise qui
s'est prolongée au delà de ce que trump
pourrait souhaiter et qui a été géré de
façon on va pas dire un petit peu
incohérente mais un petit peu au jour le
jour et il manque une vision d'ensemble
et il manque c'est vrai de ce point de
vue un leadership à cette crise qu'est
ce qui s'est passé en vérité en vérité
d'une part on connaissait pas le virus
ça c'était le cas aux etats-unis c'était
le cas ailleurs
d'autre part on a eu au départ aux
etats-unis des foyers extrêmement limité
mais extrêmement virulent notamment en
californie notamment à new york
pendant longtemps les états unis ont eu
énormément de cas mais ils étaient
concentrés dans très peu de régions à
cause de cela énormément de région n'ont
pas pratiqué le confinement
le virus s'est propagé et à un moment il
est reparti c'est ce qu'on observe
depuis à peu près un mois dans certains
états du sud c'est encore relativement
localisée les états unis sont un pays
immense donc on a on a observé des
résurgences en floride dans l'arizona au
texas en californie
ça fait quatre états sur 50 et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit alors que
cette deuxième vague en quelque sorte à
maintenant à peu près un mois de
présence
eh bien on s'aperçoit que la courbe
commence à se tasser voir à redescendre
bon skill cette crise va continuer
d'évoluer par contre ce qui est sûr
c'est que l'heure a une incidence très
importante sur le vote en novembre parce
que elle touche principalement les
personnes âgées
ce sont elles qui sont le plus
vulnérables et il ya au sein de ce
groupe démographique
énormément de supporter de bonne foi
gérald à olivier pour revenir au climat
insurrectionnel que vous dénoncez dans
plusieurs villes américaines
vous dites que ça n'a rien à voir avec
la question raciale aux états unis que
sans colle à faire du hors jeu soit
finalement là rien déclenché ce que vous
dites
ah sinon c'est parce que je dis bon là
le drame de john woo floyd a déclenché
dans la semaine qui a suivi des émeutes
à minneapolis
et puis après vous avez eu des émeutes
par association dans différentes villes
du pays
ces émeutes aujourd'hui son nom pas
elles sont pas terminées mais elles ont
dégénéré en situation insurrectionnelle
et la mort de georges floyd le racisme
systémique n'est devenu qu'un prétexte à
installer une forme de chaos permanent
et ce à quoi on observe si vraiment il y
à une situation raciale qui pose
problème il suffit de regarder les
chiffres aujourd'hui c'est pas à
portland s'est pas assis talent c'est
pas à seattle c'est plutôt à chicago où
tous les week-ends vous avez une
quinzaine de personnes qui sont
assassinés par balles et qui sont
principalement des noirs est très
souvent des enfants
on a vu une explosion de la criminalité
depuis le lancement du mouvement pour
des films d'aidé budgétisé la police dit
fan de police anglaise kate et moi j'ai
pas le terran français
quand on a vu ce mouvement contre
le la police et bien il y a eu
immédiatement une explosion de la
criminalité dans un certain nombre de
villes et les victimes de criminalité
sont des lois donc si les vies nos arts
compte pourquoi ne parle t'on pas de ces
villes à ce que vous ce que vous montrez
actuellement à l'écran ces scènes
d'émeute ce sont des scènes d'anarchie
ce sont des gens qui sont casqués qui
sont cagoulés qui ont des des gogos
soleil sur les yeux des protège ceux qui
sont venus pour faire de la castagne ça
n'a rien à voir avec le racisme
alors justement pour revenir aux
élections avec tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment aux états unis donald trump
est ce qu il peut retourner la situation
à son avantage puisque son rival joe
biden son rival démocrate est en tête
dans les sondages
est ce que c'est possible pour donald
trump alors c'est tout à fait possible
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que le plus
rassurant dans cette campagne
si l'on observe ce qui se passait il ya
quatre ans donald trump était donné
perdant par tous les sondages avec 10 ou
15 points de retard c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose et le reportage
que vous avez montré ensuite l'a très
bien démontré la campagne de joe biden
pour l'instant se limite à dénoncer de
nature et la volonté des démocrates
c'est de faire que l'élection en
novembre soit véritablement un
référendum non pas sur la politique de
donald trump
mais sur la personne de donald trump
donc le sujet d'élections aujourd'hui
c'est un adjoint hebeisen quand il
intervient c'est pour attaquer le
président en place il va venir un moment
où joe biden de vacances devra comment
dire sortir de sa cabine a actuellement
il est dans son bep semaine qu'il est
chez lui il est confiné en grande partie
lorsqu'il sort il sort masqué il donne
deux trois petites conférences sans
répondre aux questions en direct
et un moment il va devoir annoncer un
programme pas non c'est ce que lui
ferait rappelons que i plat 40 ans
d'expérience politique et qu'il a passé
36 ans de sa vie au sénat donc si vous
la faire des choses il a eu le temps de
le faire
il ya un moment où il va devoir
s'engager ne serait ce que pour décider
de sa colistière dont vous parliez
également et à ce moment là c'est lui
qui deviendra attaquable et c'est à ce
moment là où les choses pour un petit
peu se rééquilibrer si on se contente de
regarder les sondages et à mon avis ce
sont aujourd'hui de très très mauvaises
indications
parce que malheureusement pour beaucoup
de raisons les américains ne sont plus
honnête vis-à-vis des sondages beaucoup
d'américains gardent leurs idées pour
eux ils estiment que la liberté
d'expression n'existe plus de telle
façon que il puisse dire très aisément
ce qu'il pense et les gens qui ont
canalisé merci on a on appris le gâteau
re merci à vous n'aurez pas de soucis
merci à vous je rappelle que vous êtes
un journaliste chercheur alips
l'institut prospective et sécurité de
l'europe merci bien sûr voir